hi my name is willy i'm the khan academy
electrical engineering content fellow
and we got a tweet in from jane and jane
asks could you take a video could you
make a video on solving complex circuit
problems in physics for example
something something similar to this
question so jane sent us a circuit here
here it is over here
and it's an interesting looking circuit
we're going to take a shot at solving it
here and i'll tell you how i would
approach this
let's take a quick look at it we have
two batteries in it which is a bit
unusual
there's two resistors here they happen
to have the same value 1.4 ohms
there's a third resistor connected up
and the question we're being asked is to
find the what's the current
in this resistor right here so that's
what we're looking for
so the way i approach these kind of
questions first
i sort of just live with the schematic a
little bit i look at it and see if i can
imagine how the currents are flowing
and and what's going on and that a
really good way to do that
is to uh i'm going to draw this
schematic myself i'm just going to draw
it over and let my my own hand
kind of learn this circuit as we go
so i'll draw the battery the two here's
the two batteries
and i see that they're connected
together
okay that's interesting
each battery then goes to
a resistor
this goes to a resistor
and those are connected let me check
yeah those are connected together
and then they go to a third resistor
like this
now you notice what i'm doing is i'm
taking out all the funny corners and
dots and curves and things like that i'm
just going to draw a square schematic
that i can understand
now i'm going to label it just to make
sure i got everything right
so this is 11 volts
and i know from the battery symbol that
the short the short line is the minus
side and the long line is the plus side
and
same here
so
these two batteries are hooked up
exactly
the same way in the same direction this
one's also 11 volts
and that's going to prove out to be
interesting we'll call this one r1
because the problem had
i1 here we'll call this one r2
and we'll call this one
r3 of course
and the current that we're looking for
is this current right here what's that
okay so before i start doing mathematics
on this what i'm going to do is see if i
can simplify
the diagram
and what i'm going to notice here
this is this is kind of a a trick that
was done here
let's look at these batteries
these two ends of the batteries
are connected together so they are at
the same voltage
we don't know what that voltage is but
we know it's the same
and we know they're both 11 volts
and that means that this node here this
node here
and this node here
are at exactly the same voltage
with respect to this node here
this one is 11 volts lower in voltage
and this node is 11 volts lower in
nolted voltage
so what i'm going to imagine in my head
if i connected a wire between these two
nodes
this end would be at 11 volts this end
would be at 11 volts
so no current would flow through that
wire
it would have no effect on the circuit
it wouldn't dark there would be no
current like diverted from here over to
here
i'm actually going to draw that wire in
i'm going to draw that wire in
and i didn't change the circuit when i
did that
the same current goes through this wire
as before because zero goes this way the
same current goes through this wire
because zero current goes this way
because i know they're both at 11 at the
same potential
above here
right so this is a good time to redraw
this again if you look here i have two
batteries
that are hooked up their inputs
what their positive side is hooked up
together and their negative side is
hooked up together so they're they're
actually just acting like one big
battery
so let me draw that i'm going to draw
the circuit again
so it looks like this
there's my here's my combined big
battery
and it goes to
we'll relabel these again so we don't
get mixed up
okay
this is r1
this is r2
and this is r3
so this circuit looks a little simpler
i'm going to look at it again see if i
can do any more simplification so what i
recognize right here right in this area
right here r1 and r2 are in parallel
they have the same
voltage on their terminals
that means they're in parallel i know
how to simplify parallel resistors we'll
just use the the parallel resistor
equation that i have in my head
and that looks like this
let's go to this color here
okay so parallel resistors r1
and parallel with r2
i i made up this symbol two two vertical
lines that means they're in parallel and
the formula for two parallel resistors
is r1
times r2
over
r1
plus r2
now i'll plug in the values we know that
r1 and r2 are actually if we look over
here in our schematic they're the same
value
and that has a special thing when in
parallel resistors so it's actually
r
over
2r
because those resistors are the same and
you can see i can cancel that and i can
cancel that
and two parallel resistors if the
resistors are equal
is equal to half the resistance
and let's plug in the real values one
point ohms
over 2
equals
0.7
ohms that's the equivalent resistance
of these two resistors in parallel
so this is a good time to redraw this
circuit again let's let's do it again
here's our battery
this time i'm going to draw the
equivalent resistance
then we have r3 we'll put in r3 down
here
nothing's changed there
and that goes back to our
voltage source
again do some labels
so this is this is
r1 in parallel
with r2
this is r3
this is the current we want to know
right there and this is 11 volts
that's the plus side
and that's the minus side
okay we got a pretty simple circuit here
now let's let me fill in the values for
our resistor here r1 in parallel with r2
is 0.7 ohms
r3 let's go look that up remind
ourselves 2.7 ohms
now i can almost do this in my head
these are just now two series resistors
so ohm's law equals
v equals i r
this is the form of it i always
memorized
if i want to know i i'm solving for a
current so i
equals
v over r
we can start filling in values
i
equals
uh 11 volts
over
what's the resistance it's the series
resistance here so it's the sum of
these two resistors
which is 0.7
plus
2.7
if i work that out
equals 11
over
3.4
equals
okay let me actually work that out it's
volts
divided by
3.4
ohms
and that equals
3.2
something something something and that
will be in
amps
so
this right here is our answer
right there
so find the current i
i equals
3.2
amperes
and now i'm going to check
actually can check to see
if that's the answer let's see what uh
let's see what jane said she actually
sent in the answer so thank you jane for
doing that
and
there it is
so that's it
thank you very much for listening